I think that the most obvious strength
for a for Veselin Topalov is that he's a
very dynamic player he tends to
understand what what sort of positions
need need sacrifices what sort of
positions you need to be more solid and
especially he's very good at knowing
what a sacrifice in exchange which is
sacrificing a rook for a bishop or
Knight and I think if you look at all
the other top players I mean even if you
combine them I don't think any of them
have anywhere near the amount of
victories with the the sacrificing the
exchange with it uh Veselin Topalov does
he was so many specially rapid events
and blitz in the last three years I
think he won like so also Gibraltar and
then you see the the sewage tournaments
I mean very efficient and well I mean
one definitely one of the top and I
think one thing that sticks out to me
having played against au poivre so many
times is that some of the games that
I've lost I've lost in positions that I
thought I was doing completely fine or I
simply didn't understand the dynamic
possibilities that that he had in some
of the games and so like normally when
you lose lose a game at least most of
the games I've lost to other top players
you know you look at look at some games
that I've lost say Magnus Carlsen for
example or to say Fabiano Caruana
generally I think it's very easy to
pinpoint oh I did this one little thing
wrong you know I didn't calculate this
variation or I got low on time I think
it's very easy to pinpoint what went
wrong and I think one of the things with
my games against to a blob is that it
hasn't generally been that clear-cut it
hasn't been oh I made some blunder oh
you know I didn't quite understand its
opening generally something more subtle
than that and so I think that's why I'm
really looking forward to playing
against au poivre